Benvenuti alla Vittoria stickers sono
come posso aiutarti tu hai la faccia di
una che a capodanno Si divertirà
tantissimo vero comunque stare a casa a
dormire eh Ma non esiste proprio amore e
questa età se non lo sai capodanno non
sai tutto l'anno come non la fai da anni
e allora è arrivato il momento di far
prendere un po' d'aria questo
passerottina e poi si sta facendo
sentire capodanno sei fortunata tutto
l'anno come non te ne frega niente Eh
però amore Cioè se mi passi così il 2020
sarà una merda un po' di ottimismo
Seguimi matto lì la trombe Fidati di me
prendi lui perché li ha tutte e rosso e
sexy ed è anche un po' dagassi Ma guarda
che lo metti ma un'oretta le basi Cioè
tu il 31 sera e se ti tira lucido che
tua mamma ti devi guardare devi dire ma
chi Asso Domini ottone poi vai nella
prima discoteca inizia a toccare come
una Loca e il primo che ti si avvicina
lo mordi con un amante di religiosità e
te lo porti a casa Easy No però ti vesti
questo e questo era il liscia come la
tua patatina Scusa caro vieni un attimo
ma se tu diresti lei Con indosso questo
cosa faresti mmm amore ma stava
scherzando È palese allora in questo
vuoi un pigiama di pile